what's up this is Tracy Morgan this is a
wire autocomplete interview holla at me
[Music]
does Tracy Morgan use Facebook now I'm
not too much into social media because
I'm just too old does Tracy Morgan have
an octopus she's 2 years old 85 pounds
and that is my baby does Tracy Morgan
like Kevin Hart good question Tracy
Morgan doesn't like Kevin Hart Tracy
Morgan loves Kevin Hart does Tracy
Morgan thing so I can carry a note most
people can't carry a bag does Tracy
Morgan have a pet rain dare I thought
about having one but I'm gonna leave
that up to Saint Nick does Tracy Morgan
drink uncle Jamal mesmo liquor no I've
been clean for 13 years but it was fun
doing a commercial S&L pure math Shalika
does Tracy Morgan oh I can cook but I
try not to give my wife any competition
does Tracy Morgan hang out with Tina Fey
Tina Fey's a grown white woman I'm a
grown black woman I love Tina Tina's my
sister there's Tracy Morgan believe in
fate Tracy Morgan believed in faith what
is Tracy Morgan famous for just being
funny what kind of car does Tracy Morgan
have Bugatti have a Lamborghini
that's just my cause that's not even my
wife's cause what did Tracy Morgan
fishtank cost the new shark tank is
gonna be a million it's Tracy Morgan and
nada no I'm a beaver you prick is Tracy
Morgan Kanye's dad Norman's uncle is
Tracy Morgan rich no I'm wealthy
there's Tracy Morgan biz markie could be
is Tracy Morgan a country singer oh yeah
I'm Hank Williams son did Tracy Morgan
win an Emmy no but I've been nominated
twice Tracy Morgan
adlib 30 rock if I did any ad libbing we
would have been still there taping the
Tracy Morgan go to comedy school Tracy
Morgan was gifted so I was born this way
sorry
did Tracy Morgan put out a rap album I
could have what is Tracy Morgan age I'm
48 and I love it there Tracy Morgan
his octopus I don't name octopuses what
is Tracy Morgan doing I'm sitting here
talking with you
what is Tracy Morgan's zodiac chasing
Morgan is a Scorpio
very nasty I love talking to you guys
be well